so according to china there are six
areas around taiwan where they're
conducting live exercises at the moment
and according to uh taiwan they've seen
a lot of the um uh chinese aircraft fast
yet operate often out to the to the west
as well undoubtedly this is a bit of
saber rattling um and but it's a complex
history taiwan which we don't really
have time to go into today suffice to
say taiwan is about the size of wales
but one of the most densely populated uh
countries in the world
it's not just it's in the south china
sea but it's not just about taiwan it's
168 little islands that are part of of
taiwan as well and it's got real
military significance because if you can
uh populate islands that are off your
shore you can militarize them and
therefore extend your boundaries and
your borders provide greater security
for china back in 1941 taiwan was used
by the japanese to launch the attacks on
pearl harbor and general macarthur at
the time said it was almost an
unsinkable aircraft carrier such was its
strategic importance in the region it's
also china lacks any deep water ports in
the north west and northeast sorry of
the south china sea so its submarine
fleet have to do the last element of
their journey to port on the surface
which is clearly not ideal whereas
taiwan has some deep water ports would
therefore if china was to dominate
taiwan they would be able to have free
access into the pacific and also
dominate the whole southern region since
the second world war
taiwan's enjoyed a degree of
independence it's not recognized
university as an independent state um
but the people there it's it's been
become democratic and it's had an
economic revolution and therefore
there's a generation of people 24
million i think of them that live in the
island they've enjoyed the wealth the
freedom prosperity that that entails so
from a political perspective there's a
really interesting balance here china
wants to assimilate taiwan back into
china but wants to do it peacefully but
absolutely does not want to see taiwan
become independent with everything that
might involved and that's why we've got
seen this u.s policy of strategic
ambiguity over the last few years and
and if there was an attempt by
china to seize the island could taiwan
defend itself easily or what would be
the case there well from a purely
military perspective this is a david
against the goliath of of china china
has a standing army of 2 million taiwan
has a standing army less than 10 that
size
china has 2400 modern uh fast jet
aircraft next generation oozing uh
technology taiwan has about 450 and they
are very old airplanes and the china has
the biggest navy in the world so that
would dominate the whole region so how
would taiwan manage its security it
would look to friends it would look to
allies and that's why it's cultivated a
friendship with the us over the years
the challenge though really is would the
u.s come to its age should anything
happen and of course uh as is happening
with russia invading ukraine nato is
being very clear not to get directly
involved so china will have assessed
that so from a military perspective
looks quite bleak the one positive is
that taiwan is an island and therefore
any assault would have to be an
amphibious assault if you want to clock
back to the second world war of overlord
when we had to liberate france we only
had a gap of 20 miles not 100 miles and
any uh invasion force would be really
really vulnerable so it's it's it's a
difficult equation from a military
perspective and and what's next what can
we expect to happen in the coming days
well bunkley the tensions the region
have been around for a long time um and
i think what's heightened at the moment
is the russian invasion of ukraine
because china has long had ambitions
about taiwan but wouldn't really have
known what the west's response would be
have seen what's happened with russia
going to ukraine has seen the fact that
america has not got directly intervened
and therefore there is a risk and let's
face it ukraine is a sovereign nation
whereas taiwan is not recognized as such
so and there's no question that china
might have felt emboldened in this
strategic balance but china will also be
well aware that the three pillars of
this are military where they have an
advantage but economic and diplomatic
are really interesting the west has been
very unified in its response to his
sanctions against russia if that was to
happen against china and china does most
of its trade most of its economic wealth
comes from its export trade that would
have a devastating effect on china
and likewise the u.s will have been
concerned that the delicate balance in
the region might have been upset by
china misinterpreting the actions in
ukraine so undoubtedly the rhetoric has
been increased from america they want to
make sure that chinese do not
misunderstand that they fully understand
the risks and nancy pelosi's visit
whilst provocative is undoubtedly part
of that balancing and from a military
perspective there's a piece that's
existed for 80 years i can't see any
reason at the moment why that piece will
get disrupted sean bell as always thanks
so much